it's the end of the world as you know it
every human on earth suddenly went
extinct
and it's time for nature to make its
ultimate comeback
what would happen to your home and your
city
why would this Doom the planet to a
nuclear meltdown
and would any trace of human existence
manage to live on
this is what if and here's what would
happen if humans suddenly went extinct
whether it was a global pandemic a
planet-wide volcanic event or a gigantic
Space Rock we reached the end of the
line for our species
every single human on earth is gone
for good
now while there's no hope for Humanity
to make a comeback we'd be leaving
behind a lot of stuff
cities highways
waste
time to see just how long it would take
for the last remaining traces of human
life to disappear
but first here's one thing that'll help
you survive any kind of Apocalypse
bespoke post it's a monthly membership
club that delivers you top shelf goods
from under the radar brands or as I like
to call it a box of awesome check these
out bespoke post sent me a point box and
a pickle box now anyone who knows me
knows that I'm about 70 vinegar and
about 30 salt so a pickle box right up
my alley check this out first of all
Sucker Punch kosher Dills are you
kidding me that's what I'm eating first
there's the pickling spice pickled
onions I love pickled Cactus I've never
tried that but that's amazing oh and
pickled jalapenos the point box check
this out this is for your EDC your
everyday carry you gotta have a knife
and this pocket Samurai keychain knife
this is so cool super sharp though watch
out this brass Grafton mini twist it's a
pen and it's the coolest pen on ever
owned and check out this closed Helix
key ring this is how I get into the
office every day bespoke post offers you
awesome new boxes every month you fill
in a preference quiz and they introduce
you to Brands and products you didn't
know of before from outdoor gear to live
oysters every box of awesome has around
70 dollars worth of goods inside but
costs you only a fraction of the value
now before you get your box you can
preview it and decide if you want to
keep it or swap it for a different one
and if you didn't feel like any of the
options you can always skip a month or
cancel any time and now you can get 20
off your first box of awesome just click
on the link in the description and enter
what if 20 at checkout or go to
bespokeost.com what if 20. hey with
bespoke post you might just last in this
scenario a little longer
[Music]
week of life on Earth without humans
would be tough for all the pets
without you your furry companions would
need to get outside and find food for
themselves
so hopefully you left a window open for
them
your peace lily would stand no chance
but that wouldn't be the only thing at
stake with you gone for just one week
soon the world will become Radioactive
the thing is our nuclear plants produce
nuclear waste these pools of spent
nuclear fuel need to be constantly
cooled off with water
and that water needs electricity to
circulate without humans to maintain the
electrical infrastructure soon nuclear
facilities around the world would start
losing power and that would cause a
disastrous chain reaction
the water that used to cool down nuclear
waste would stop running and begin to
boil off
this would expose nuclear waste causing
it to catch fire
all this waste would explode covering
the planet in deadly radioactive
chemicals
ecosystems around the world would start
dying from all the radioactivity and
many of these chemicals would remain
dangerous for 300 years
and some like plutonium would stay
radioactive for the next 240
000 years
but let's not get too far ahead of
ourselves
[Music]
okay about one year after we're gone
nature would begin to reclaim our roads
and highways
moss and fungus would grow everywhere
and when the first winter hit the planet
these roads would start to crumble
all the freezing and thawing would cause
water from melted snow to flow into the
cracks in these cracked vacant streets
new plants would grow
there would be weeds like mustard and
Shamrock and in a few more years grass
in forests poisoned by radiation there
wouldn't be any birds singing this year
but further away from these deadly areas
animal populations would start to Boom
there wouldn't be any humans to hunt
them or force them out of their natural
homes anymore
without pesticides insects would
reproduce quicker taking over the globe
this would mean much more food for all
kinds of animals like reptiles and
rodents
[Music]
okay fast forwarding a bit you'd start
to see our empty cities undergo major
changes London's Trafalgar Square would
be growing young trees
Berlin's Brandenburg gate would be
surrounded by Forest
in New York City a lot would be going on
Underground
half a century would have gone by since
the last time anyone from a maintenance
crew managed any of its
753 Subway pumps that prevented
rainstorms from flooding the rails
there would now be a network of
underground Rivers below New York's
concrete landscape
steel columns supporting the streets
above would buckle and create waterways
through Park Avenue and Wall Street
your abandoned house and your
neighborhood would all be in pretty bad
shape
roofs would leak Nails would rust
buildings would start collapsing
in major cities streets would be
littered with glass falling from
decaying skyscrapers
[Music]
although skyscrapers would crumple into
massive piles of rubble despite the city
being flooded New York's Grand Central
Station and other Stone buildings like
it would still be intact
and good news I guess all your now
worthless money would still be safe and
sound in Bank faults that would never be
reopened
but famous works of art wouldn't be so
lucky
without climate control and electricity
Museum vaults would be less fortunate
water would leak in and mold would cover
everything
ironically thousand-year-old Ceramics
would continue to survive just like
fossils
[Music]
500 years later a forest would Now cover
where your home once stood
but buried in the dirt could still be
the remains of many of your aluminum
appliances and stainless steel cookware
sadly you wouldn't be around to cook any
good meals with them anymore
with every stretch of black asphalt now
overtaken by trees and grasses
temperatures would drop all over the
world the atmosphere would undergo
changes as it continues to recover
without humans there would be less
carbon dioxide in it
the initial boom in animal populations
from after our disappearance would
stabilize by this point
Predators like wolves would once again
roam around Europe hunting in packs
[Music]
jumping way ahead into the Future Would
anything remain of human civilization
well you'd still be able to make out the
faces of former U.S presidents in the
granite of Mount Rushmore but don't
expect many facial features a lot of the
rock would significantly erode
there would also be some remaining
pieces of Egypt's Great Pyramid of Giza
and the Great Wall of China but time
wouldn't be kind to them and both would
be barely recognizable versions of the
former world wonders
at this point everything that humans
left behind on Earth would be consumed
by the Sun as it expands and destroys
the planet
but if you're worried about Humanity
disappearing into nothingness well there
still could be a human footprint to be
found
the Voyager space probes would be
somewhere out beyond our solar system
maybe some alien civilization would find
them and learn that once upon a time
there was human life on Earth
but what if those aliens discovered us a
little sooner
like tomorrow
well that's a story for another
what if
[Music]